-Performing "Let Me Be
Great" from her album
"As Above, So Below,"
please welcome
Sampa The Great featuring
Angelique Kidjo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Women vocalizing ]
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Ah-cha cha ah-cha ♪
♪ Ka ka-king ♪
♪ These certainly are
the signs ♪
♪ Many men left
to their own devices ♪
♪ Tell the story,
leaving out the cries ♪
♪ It's "Say me, say me" ♪
♪ Quite sucks to be the boss ♪
♪ The hunter should be licking
at my...♪
♪ I'm a lion now ♪
♪ King, yes, applause,
I'm feelin' it ♪
♪ But of course, what is
the cost I'm healing now ♪
♪ I'm dealing with my heroes
always messing with my flaws ♪
♪ When I was younger,
you was on my walls ♪
♪ Now it's "Replace this" ♪
♪ There will never be another ♪
♪ So I figure I could carve
my own path ♪
♪ Soaring, I'm an exhibit
on my name ♪
♪ I'm Sammy, I'm Tembo, I'm Eve,
I'm Sampa, I'm great ♪
♪ Remember when there's doubt,
fear ♪
♪ You would have my voice
and the song in your ear ♪
♪ You can time travel,
any month, any year ♪
♪ You're the greatest,
yeah, I told you ♪
♪ 'Cause it's what
you need to hear ♪
Ladies and gentlemen,
Angelique Kidjo!
-♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
♪ Let me, let me ♪
♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
-♪ Forever ever, and ever ever
and ever ever, and ever ♪
♪ I'mma be great ♪
♪ Huh, and you can never fail ♪
♪ And even if you fall,
you prevail ♪
♪ And you can never lessen with
a lesson ♪
♪ And I've been pressing,
something ♪
♪ It's not about impressing,
I'm expressing ♪
♪ And every path I pave still
stressing ♪
♪ And Simon said,
"Stay in your lane" ♪
♪ If I stayed, I'd be playing
with them little rhyme books ♪
♪ Singing Tupac hooks ♪
♪ Still ignoring the fact
that a queen named Lauryn ♪
♪ Said that I could conquer
any hill ♪
♪ That's how I feel,
that's how I feel ♪
♪ My vision, I'm impeccable ♪
♪ Every strength gain,
like I said, detectable ♪
♪ Looking to the future for
a vision, no spectacle ♪
♪ It's legacy,
it's what I see, huh ♪
♪ Remember when there's doubt,
fear ♪
♪ You would have a voice
and a song in your ear ♪
♪ You can time travel,
any month, any year ♪
♪ You're the greatest,
yeah, I told you ♪
♪ 'Cause it's what
you need to hear ♪
-♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
♪ Let me, let me ♪
♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
[ Women vocalizing ]
♪♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
-♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
-[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
-♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
-[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪♪
-♪ This song says it right now ♪
-♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
-♪ Great ♪
-♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
-♪ No matter what you think
of me ♪
-♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
-♪ On my journey ♪
-♪ Let me ♪
-♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
-♪ Let me ♪
-♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
-♪ Let me, let me be great ♪
-♪ Let me ♪
-♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
♪ Ahhh, yeah ♪
♪ Sampa The Great,
Sampa The Great ♪
♪ Sampa The Great, Sampa ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes! Yes!
"Let Me Be Great"!
You are great!
Come on, you know! Come on, bud!